andreas est avec nous il va nous parler
de tout ce qui se passe sur les chaînes
youtube il ya du très très lourd et vous
allez voir le magnéto qu'il a
aujourd'hui
cela a été fait dans la rue du très très
lourd andreas qui étaient bloqués ou
fautes directes sur la tête de ma mère
on dirait qu est le combat traire
j'adore donc ça devrait aller vers le
bureau j'adore il est très belle aime
pas chérie france jerry à l'onu on est
du bon travail aujourd'hui on a dû loin
je vous dit on à du très très lourd on a
dû en effet nous de trois images en
amérique on y verra après tu vas nous
montrer de madiba ces partis aujourd'hui
le bdr s'est penché sur les chaînes
youtube alors vous connaissez le
principe me suis penché sur les tutos
les tutos c'est des gens qui se fichait
de qui postent la vidéo pour vous
puissiez refaire la même chose chez vous
ouais à là je me suis penché sur les
tutos beauté d'un youtuber en
particulier son truc à lui c'est les
tutos coiffure problème c'est que sa
coiffure est plus proche de celle de
gérard jugnot que de celle de jean-louis
david
le rendu est pas ouf numéro 2 mais
qu'est-ce que sur la chaîne gulli
nouveau brancher l'appareil
c'est génial alors du coup qu'est ce que
ça va être la coiffure en garde
attention ça peut être un dos tres bien
sûr l'accord génie alors si je l'aimé
bien ça tombe bien parce que moi je me
suis baladé un peu sur sa chaîne près
j'ai remarqué que son petit péché mignon
sa patte artistique c'était l'effet de
surprise est allé voir que quand il fait
le reveal de sa nouvelle coiffure le gaz
peut rendre jaloux tous les coiffeurs de
paris anne après avoir un c'est mes
cheveux je fais un petit soin je reviens
pour vous montrer le résultat final ça
fait la beauté en herbe et j'espère
qu'il va continuer l'ont pas j'adore ce
mec
allez on va le suivre on va le serait
alors on la regarde tous les jours va le
suivre baïla que des coiffeurs il a des
abonnés beaucoup dans les abruzzes moi
je vais m'abonner après ça je suis passé
sur la chaîne d'une prof de théâtre
on est là pour nous apprendre un peu à
jouer des émotions c'est important où
elle tourne des vidéos avec massa
meilleur élève qui doit nous jouer la
terreur problème c'est que si ça
meilleurs élèves jouent la terreur comme
ça je suis pas pressé de voir les autres
monter sur scène sur la première chaise
la comédienne a prise d'une terreur
absolue elle est bien là
au delà du talent exprimer des émotions
et des sentiments nécessite un vrai
travail
[Applaudissements]
après ça je suis passé jeter un oeil sur
les tutos d'un prof de danse
ouais alors si en boîte galéré un peu
denses et que comme moi ça vous bloque
un peu pour pécho ne suivent et surtout
pas les conseils de ce gala ça vous
servir à rien c'est de leur beau
eh bien on dément propre rôle mais comme
un vrai atout des chaînes youtube on a
dû très très loin sur tout est parti
dans la rue et la cie franchement on en
a pleuré de rire avec les équipes
regardent un petit extrait n'a pas un
petit extrait on a bien sûr près d'un
petit exercer dans un instant au regard
d'un petit extrait je suis dans l'ouest
de la france dans la petite ville de
sucé-sur-erdre s'invente pas il va aller
poser des questions aux locaux vides
avec moi est-ce que vous l'aimez vous de
ville en quelques mots ah j'adore sucer
oui c'est celui d'andré as tu t'es
intéressé aux chaînes youtube encore eu
dans un instant t était donc passe pas
mal de villes de france
exactement là qui fait qu'ils portent un
nom difficile à porter mes revenus on y
revient juste après sur youtube j'ai
terminé avec une chaîne de self-défense
en espagne alors il ya deux trucs qui
m'interpelle mais si vous allez en
espagne fait attention visiblement la
bassée courant de se battre avec une
pelle à tarte et deuxièmement vous allez
voir que le prof pour la démonstration a
choisi un élève un peu plus chaud que
milan baston genou pendant toute la
vidéo il s'est un peu magnifique
[Applaudissements]
ensuite ses rivaux la sas et je sais que
tu vas dans la rue tous les jours a bien
sûr un homme qui est relaté un homme de
terrain
c'est ça ouais ya un petit truc avant ou
pas vas-y on y va ce matin juste pour
vous je sais que vos fans de foot ouais
vous tous les matins j'arrive au bureau
à 5h30 l'équipe juste pour un jour mais
bon c'est vrai de 5h30 et du cou
du coup un bas ce matin j'ai vu que pour
le match de ce soir bordeaux saint
pétersbourg il y avait une petite galère
vous laisse regarder
alors voilà là il faut la compo de
l'équipe vous allez voir que bon ben on
voit qu'ils jouent qu'il a joués qui va
pas jouer mais il ya un joueur qui
jouera pas ce soir parce qu'il ya eu une
petite galère qui a rien à voir avec le
foot hein je vous laisse regarder ces
cocos rim 1 ce soir est prise au cirque
au bc cocon il n'aurait non prix là il
sort dans deux mois ne peut pas jouer ce
soir calcul il a alors oui faut bien de
préciser pendant moi d'ailleurs et
beaucoup les gens qui nous regardent en
prison on leur fait dire ce que c'est
vrai qu'on est très regardée là bas
alors bon on arrive son micro dans les
vases y voilà j'ai commencé à faire le
tour de france des villes qui porte un
nom difficile à porter je pensais qu'on
allait y aller ensemble mais c'est vrai
que niveau calendrier ou emploi du temps
c'est un peu chaud on fera des trucs
ensemble
du coup j'y suis allée solo alors là je
suis dans une ville je peux pas vous
dire le nom je vais vous dire que quand
on va là bas et qu'on demande aux gens
sur place d'où ils viennent ce qu'ils
nous répondent à notre oreille à nous ça
paraît un peu chelou partie je suis dans
l'ouest de la france dans la petite
ville de sucé-sur-erdre ça s'invente pas
il valait poser des questions aux
communes avec moi bonjour monsieur
comment vous appelez bonjour la veille
françois vous venez d'où je viens de
sucer pardon je viens de sucé sur erdre
oui on dit si c'est tout court est-ce
que vous avez des commerçants ici
houllier d'un plan de commerçants à
sucer et un boulanger fc alors il ya
encore denis a su c'est aussi un
fleuriste à sucer
de boulangerie à terrain de foot à sucer
et en plus il ya une belle équipe a su
série qu est ce que vous les aimez votre
ville en quelques mots ah j'adore ce
civil originaire de cissé sur et amener
du coup j'avais vite à paris est ce que
venir à sucer c'est tromper non c'est
bien d'accord vous êtes le responsable
de cette boutique qui s'appelle lm je
crois savoir qu'il ya plusieurs
boutiques et même en france
alors elle aime paris elle aime à
marseille et lm sucer je vois pas
beaucoup de voitures dans le point
comment ça se passe au niveau du trafic
à sucer n'y a pas de qu asus et
fukushima
[Musique]
bonjour je suis avec le maire de la
commune de sucé sur erdre et vous vous
avez combien de temps qu'il y à 7500
personnes asus et voilà tout ça pour
pour un seul maire ça ça fait beaucoup
de boulot alors j'avais quelques
habitants du coin est ce que vous avez
un petit mot adressé aux touristes pour
qu'ils viennent vous voir sucer la bombe
c'est pas moi qui les dire
[Musique]
montpellier
soyez bien il adore slimani nourrir des
effectifs et son compte ici malachie
peszko temps